limited edition double bubble gum pink
vinyl with gold splashes i found this at
a time where i was uh
let's just say uh experimenting
hello it's steve lacey me
steve lacey and i'm about to spend some
of gq's money
[Music]
so the first category is very gq we're
gonna take a look at some clothes
so here we have a gucci belted wool
crepe jumpsuit for three thousand nine
hundred and eighty dollars inspired by
vintage designs the white lug jumpsuit
is reminiscent of the silhouettes
popular in the 70s i'm trying to find
what my pant is right now but i don't
think it's wide especially with like
white and flared it's too it's too big
it's too old-school we need to move this
way not that way we reminisced enough
let's be futuristic now but i like gucci
okay we got the bottega vanetta vest for
three thousand seven hundred dollars
this is really nice got the intertwined
nylon vest snap closure unlined
beautiful parakeet green made in italy
this
this one's nice we got the juicy couture
velour jogger suit for
dollars
i mean this is you know an iconic design
got the juicy couture jacket features
bejeweled monogram and silver tone
zipper pull yeah it's cute i wouldn't
get this one though because i hate
tapered legs
just to cut on this is just not good but
the sentiment of the juicy couture
sweatsuit is hot all day but on me it's
not happening my shoulder is too broad
too for this jacket so here we have the
jean-paul gaultier the naked maxi dress
for six hundred and eighty dollars
stretch nylon jersey dress graphic
pattern printed throughout and this is a
collaboration with lada volkova who will
absolutely adore it's nylon the last
scene made in italy blah blah blah yeah
this is pretty cool i love this dress
but i think of all four of them i'm
gonna have to go with the bottega vest
yeah
it's the most modular
thing of all of these things
[Music]
so the next category
is furniture so for the first option we
have
werner penton's living tower for 25
465 dollars it is an organically shaped
living tower furniture sculpture that
was designed by danish designer werner
panson in 1969. i have this at home
actually for those of you who know me
you know my last album apollo 21 this is
the piece of furniture that we shot with
and it's actually at my house in orange
so i can't choose this one i usually uh
sit just like regular or some friends
will do it and
it's really fun my nephews love it like
he was just on the top sitting
it's really cool and so for the next one
we have the boomerang desk for 85 000.
it's expensive made of fiberglass and
metal has three drawers on the right and
one deep file drawer on the left comes
with a key
this is pretty beautiful this one okay
the helio and demio contemporary art bed
53
929
and 51 cents is the price of this one it
was made in 1987 italian bed helio
endemio designed by luigi ontani
silver and gold leaf finish and helio
endemio
beyond the smiling crescent moon the
radiant sun's gaze meets the eye of the
creator who at the same time is both
divine and profane that's you know
that's pretty on par to you know i'll be
talking [ __ ] so that's pretty cool
boxing glove arm chairs for 42
500 a pair made in switzerland leather
manufactured at seven to one scale it's
pretty cool but probably still gonna go
with the bed
they're cool but the [ __ ] bed is just
like out of this world i'm going with
the helio endemio contemporary art bed
for 53
929
and 51 cents that's my choice the next
category we have here are instruments
this is a good one i love instruments
yeah they're kind of uh my life okay
felipe dubrey prince paisley guitar for
34 522.77
this unique piece took six months to
build the guitar body is made of real
paisley tissue and finished with varnish
ebony fretboard played by wendy melvoyne
a guitarist for the revolution we left
wendy
on stage at wembley with prince in 1990.
that was a weak spot that's a cheap spot
you know that's uh you know it's prince
so it's definitely interesting i mean i
wouldn't jump to this but you know the
prince should you know that that [ __ ]
just jumps but i like the little gold
thing coming out but
yeah it's a funny looking body i want to
design this wendy i've met her before
yeah i've met windy before i know you
know because anderson packs
but deja pal wendy and lisa
my tour manager tina she's like the
coolest person in the world she knows
everybody said oh you don't know what
i'm uh when dealing with this thing i'm
like oh [ __ ] this is casual it's windy
at least i'm like what's up
that's just crazy
but they're really nice oh okay this is
funny guitar hero 2
guitar controller for 343.70
this does not cost that much you can get
these shits on ebay for like 60 dollars
i mean i play it in arcades some arcades
i go to literally to just play guitar
hero but yeah they have the arcade game
you can buy
but i'd rather it's cheaper you know on
the console
if ever i'm in an arcade
that's what i do i find you know if they
have it and i'm playing just playing
with strangers just [ __ ] them up
cliffs of dover
that song used to make me so angry i
would literally like want to just break
it but it
just wanted it though i was just like i
need to know how to play this song
but yeah eclipse was over we have a
double flute for 475
in the key of low d minor double flutes
were originally made of clay and used as
temple flutes in ancient mexico this is
a pretty cool flute
but um i'm not 100 2 000. so i'm going
to pass on this one i was playing the
trumpet for a second i love the trumpet
yeah that's my favorite horn i remember
this kid franklin he's just showing me
different skills and stuff and so i took
one home he's like just take this i'm
like i'm pretty sure this is the
school's but he gave it to me as a gift
so i'm like
i'm gonna keep i'm gonna take it home
yeah shout out to franklin uh
and so next we have an antique heart for
thirty thousand two hundred 297.91
made in 1914 weighs 81 pounds accented
with 23
carat hand gilding this is pretty
beautiful this is pretty beautiful you
know for this one i'm gonna go with the
heart
if i'm gonna get a prince guitar i'm
gonna get one of a design i actually
like this is just okay
so
the prince history couldn't even fill me
on that one i'm going with the heart
it's a beautiful instrument carrots and
laurel accents and this is it this is in
my living room all day
let's look at some records you guys all
right let's come in strong so we got
erica badou badouism for
323.40 mint condition includes rare
hyped sticker still sealed it's a pretty
good one
we love erica i do yeah i mean i think i
grew up just listening to this in
passing this is gonna make me sound like
a young
dude but i don't care i feel like my
erica moment happened with the new
america part one and two
i feel like that to me was like a sonic
blueprint for like what i wanted to do
like the synthesizers and and what she
did with real instruments and how she
took samples and like replayed them and
her voice
yeah those are my erica albums but i
love badouism as well i mean how can you
not
so here we have one of my favorite bands
funkadelic maggot brain for 699. this is
mint condition vinyl
1971 original pressed rare matrix run
out etching variation disc is well kept
i like this one a lot that's rare and
then jay-z i just want to love you give
it to me for 25 we got the 2000 original
rockefeller records pressing original
sleeve
first single written and produced by
pharrell and chad the neptunes
oh black malt super rainbow yeah
wow
uh we got the black mall super rainbow
dandelion gum
225
gatefold sleeve with scratch and sniff
front cover wow
that's pretty cool
limited edition double bubble gum pink
vinyl with gold splashes only a thousand
copies were made i found this at a time
where i was uh
let's just say uh experimenting
this is pretty cool i mean this the
scratch of sniff the gold splashes
beautiful oof
it's definitely between this one and the
parliament record i'm gonna have to go
with the funkadelic record i think
through time that one's going to be like
the most
like black male super rainbow's dope but
it's not on the level of icon
[Music]
gifts for my boo let's go get some gifts
for my boo okay this big ish box of
peonies for 230 these are beautiful
flowers assortment of 50 stems of organ
grown peonies that ship straight to your
booze doorstep okay this is funny
flaming hot cheetos in a napkin pond
yeah okay mate with real cheese egg free
peanut-free shellfish-free soy-free tree
nut-free then i know all these freezers
about hot cheetos i'd be eating these
[ __ ] and i'd be feeling bad but
this is actually kind of
kind of okay
wow
nice then we have the lorraine schwartz
18 karat diamond bracelet for
six
41
dollars no
no
definitely not it's too expensive i
wouldn't even buy anything like this for
myself
i can't get this for the nobody else
we have plush love cuffs
for 16 16.95
but see that's not for them that one's
for us
so i think one for them i'm gonna have
to go with the peonies
for sure that's a nice one for 230
dollars
thank you gq for this wonderful shopping
spree
all my money is intact